Les vidéos les plus populaires du web c'est les vidéos de chat...
Du coup, j'ai voulu en faire une !
Bon évidemment, dans un premier temps il faut déjà un chat !
Non de préférence, un chat plutôt mignon
Parce que les vieux gros en général tout le monde s'en fout
Ensuite pour filmer votre chat, il faut une qualité d'image absolument dégueulasse.
Alors pour ça, je vous conseille d'utiliser un téléphone portable
Et de préférence un peu nul
Ça donne ça !
Parfait, c'est extrêmement dégueulasse, avec un son bien pourri !
Prochaine étape : il vous faut un lieu un peu spécial
Moi j'ai choisi les toilettes !
D'abord, votre chat doit être dans une position un peu intrigué
C'est la qu'on comprend le principe de la vidéo
Ensuite on enchaine quelques petites actions mignonnes avec les pattes
Une
Deux
Trois
Quatre
Cinq
À la fin, il faut toujours "concluer" la vidéo par un évènement d'intensité un peu supérieure
Un peu comme un climax ou un dénouement
En général, c'est à ce moment là que les gens ils font : "Oh naaan !"
Bien évidemment, il faut que l'aperçu de votre vidéo
s'arrête sur le chat en train de faire une action complètement folle
Et le summum !
La crème de la crème !
C'est de mettre un titre de vidéo
avec une accroche digne des plus grands slogants publicitaires américains
"Chat dans toilettes"
"Le perroquet dit le mot bonjour"
"Le chien dit wesh wesh la famille"
"Un chat fait du break dance en haut de la pyramide du Louvre"
Bah il est où ton petit bouchon ?